[Music] I do
n't know why, you're staring at me all the time. Let's
leave early. I'm going to change my clothes, so please tell me
something later. I'll be
waiting for you in the snow room. [
Music]
Excuse me. I feel like I'm being
rude.  I wonder if it's because of my
intentions.I want to blame it on my imagination.I
try to blame it on my imagination.But why are the two of us alone?Looks like you went back to your hometown.How was it?
Everyone seemed to be in good spirits, and most importantly, it
was a rehearsal.  What kind of man is he? He's the
acceptor. Why does he know his name? Why is he
saying that he knows what it
means? Did he say that he
couldn't become the acceptor unless there was a solid exchange of identities?
They were also handing out
books, so I received it at the last minute.In other words, I was
defeated by what I received at the last minute.I
should have given it to them too, but I never heard anything about it.It's just me.In
short, I didn't get anything to talk about.  I wonder why you don't like it.It would have been
easier to not get involved in the business, but
since you're a lazy person, you want me to take care of your troubles.I'm
sorry, but I couldn't
think of an Oshita that would satisfy Hitoshi-sama.
So, what is Oshita? Did you pay that much for rehearsal?
Yes, I was very happy with the night's dream. It seemed
that you were very satisfied with the night, and we had a
party where we did our best.  I'm going to clean up the
wrinkles right away so please don't touch me.
Please excuse me before it gets stained.